[Music]
hug be mobile
drink lots of water if you're sweating
be drinking some abd
we're gonna go out to the roadings
vehicle shots as with any vehicle stuff
there's a of course a bit of a danger
involved i'm surprised the car didn't
crash the sun is just now rising shoot
ends when it sets they have a long day
ahead of us three honks means go
two honks means i am stopping
pretending with slapping on the
today we are rocking the 8k helium 24 to
7 to sigma lenses variable indeed like
sunglasses for your camera all right the
shot like this a lot of moving parts a
lot of people you got to film the whole
take in one go so we need to walk
through it with everybody make sure we
all know how it's going to work
in this shot we're going to run the
whole scene that means i'm going to have
him get in the bus we're going to be
throwing down the sandbags
and that's when we hit the body danny
you're gonna be driving in the camera
car in front of us don't hit the sandbag
we're gonna come to a stop after we hit
them we'll throw the car in reverse and
we're gonna back up over them again boom
boom we're gonna stop or run the rest of
the scene
driving the imaginary car
me and sam are sitting here next to each
other
jake once we hit the body we should be
by the sandbags he'll be waiting there
just for now walking next to us
what the [ __ ] are you doing this is the
wrong way everything guys i really
really appreciate it
let's get the vehicles in position but
here's the best part
you don't have to imagine any of this
because this is actually the situation
that we're in all right i'm just going
over my lines there's a lot of them so i
don't want to trip over any of them and
i still want them to feel natural my mom
used to make me do this thing when i was
a kid to remember math problems
where i'd have to walk around the house
and memorize math problems in my head so
i could just say them i always hated it
but i'm thanking her now because it
makes it a lot easier to remember lines
when you're acting thanks mom all i'm
trying to say is that friends are
important
back to one back to one
now keep this pace up so we can get the
ending seam done
more character niko
be a better actor okay
so directing tip for you guys all out
there if somebody's not giving their
best performance just ask them ask them
to give you more acting and
there you go it's all about finding the
right amount usually you just need to
ask for more until you get it yeah the
secret of jack nicholson's performance
is he's always acting at 100
very difficult for actors to reach that
[Laughter]
so we've uh we've come to conclusion
that dobie the trickster god lives in
the desert because whenever we go to the
desert the ultimate tricks happen it's
currently 10 a.m
and we've been out here for at least two
hours now so i'm assuming we're a little
behind because we're still getting the
yeah we just finished like the first
setup yeah
uh i'm not getting any audio off the
sennheiser mic and we're out in the
middle of the desert
so
you're not getting any audio output not
even on here it's not reading
make some noise uh and some might think
it's just he's just a harmless
mischievous trickster god like haha your
microphone doesn't work for a little
while i wouldn't transmit to our
transmitter
it wasn't holding power we tried
plugging into the camera didn't work for
a while but then it stopped working and
kind of get buzzy come listen to what i
just got because it's very there's a lot
of static and little by little
throughout the day it got worse and
worse and you know like when you're
trying to fix something you don't fix it
instantly so then another person comes
in and they're like here can i try and
you're like well
uh and then they kind of start trying
anyways and then somebody else steps in
he goes no no let me try until you get
like a chain of five or six people all
trying to fix the same problem and just
it just gets worse
i don't know what's going on guys
guys guys guys guys first off it's not a
setting we set all the settings and it
started working it's a hardware issue up
the uh input volume just a little bit
it doesn't clip at all when you're at 95
let's just do it
you hit the you arm it no i know yeah
it's literally going to like negative
46.
we can figure this out today back in the
house and film this first thing in the
morning
we gotta do this then we're gonna do
this we'll just film it and then we'll
do wild lines in the van like hey
spencer do you have any idea what's
going on here and spencer ascertained
that well you can ask the man himself
we ended up finding out there's the
board inside of the microphone it's what
you put battery in what happens is it'll
work for a certain amount of time and
then it will cut off and die for a film
shoot you have to have it last the
entire time unbelievably spencer also
had a second shotgun microphone
do you think the hot sauce scene will
happen today
it's the 360.
the car drive over those two sandbags
and then in post using visual magic
replace the bags with me
shadow
flop
my name's steve dundee got a crocodile
in me now
you can't see him but it'll come out
when you're least expecting it's one
shot it's one shot like we're literally
hiking up that [ __ ] mountain so i
want to bring a lot of stuff
it's a specialty shot it's a it's a
pretty large mound of dirt i'd say it's
a mountain
akin to
kilimanjaro it's a wide shot of the van
driving and then it's a
crash
zoom out
and then some characters run in front of
the foreground okay adrian's rolling all
right give me an action three two one
action
three
two
one
go
said we're not fired
we got the shot
it was all worth it
we're trying to accomplish a following
shot on the van
and having the camera locked off with
the dusty road is just way too shaky now
we're about to literally just put the
camera and adrian on the roof
called the boogie board
i'm good i'm good
wonderful
i heard on page 155 of sam's
top 10 games you can play in your head
by yourself oh my god is that the actual
wait how did you get the hooly
it's a real thing
thanks to pubg mobile for sponsoring
this video if you're interested in
downloading pubg mobile click the link
in the description it's free am i about
to get a chicken dinner
unless i die
please don't die
this is like literally the first time
i've ever played this game
is using the gamertag
77 so if you go and friend him
you might have a chance to play with him
online
obviously it's really intense oh who's
shooting right there uh 210 210
what does that mean get on the compass
up
oh oh that's that's that's great
okay daddy's house is clear down there
we're set here on sophomore yeah i just
saw him oh i hate shots
off the street from grandma's house
it's the most robust mobile game i think
i've ever seen you're not playing pubg
mobile you're just playing pubg
check the windows there's window in
there
we got two people there's a whole nother
squad right on my body where you died oh
and i died i cannot freaking believe how
robust this game is
dude oh my god we're about to get the
dinner this is legitimately actually
really fun so i think you'll enjoy it if
you're around with some friends
you got them yeah got them god let's
finish them off one guy one guy one guy
one guy no wait one i'm using my
bandages i have so many bandages keep an
eye out for something that's three
versus one guy he's somewhere in here i
am still bandaging up make sure you're
in the circle dude did you get a red
bull focus who's shooting it's not us
when you're matched behind you where
okay that's definitely not me shooting
by the way god damn it
yeah
i don't know where you at man i'm right
behind you
here's him in front of you i can't aim
him high up right this out directly
sounds crash
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was my very very first chicken
dinner dude i got that i got that screen
cap too let's go
download pubg mobile for free
there's a link in the description below
you simply go to your app store of your
device
and download it
pubg mobile has a new arcade mode with
28 players in one of the six following
variations shotguns sniper rifles all
weapons melee only pistols and item
heaven
the realistic graphics of the game are
powered by unreal engine and you can
communicate in real time with your team
using in-game voice chat dude i almost
forgot to announce we are going to buy
someone a chicken dinner we're gonna
send
one person
a chicken dinner from a restaurant in
their area courtesy of corridor digital
go online play pubg mobile if you win in
the game screen cap it take that screen
cap put it on instagram tag at corridor
digital we will randomly select one
chicken dinner winner we will buy you a
chicken dinner
for you and your family or you and your
friends from somewhere in your hometown
just tag us and we'll pick somebody
right after this video goes up hey
bridger's here
boom hit nick in the face and then both
of them turn and start shooting at me
and i take cover boom boom boom boom
boom before the sun sets oh we are
losing sunlight quickly you can
literally see the shadow
moving where we're at there's no room
there's no time so we gotta move the bus
to a clearing we can finish this fight
scene
grabbing it like a racehorse here
here's
why are you putting the camera or should
i say something profound yeah
dogs oh crap danny we need another lens
we need it now you need a lens yeah go
get it
daddy we need the legs
hurry hurry
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you may remember
sam and i made a little bet guaranteed
two-day shipping so some some poor
innocent unknowing amazon delivery
contractor is going to get this package
and they're going to have to make the
decision as to whether or not they want
to drive a hundred miles one way
my goodness well i sure hope they make
it in time i'll bet you
two to one it arrives i owe you 20. if
it doesn't arrive
on or before the 30th then you owe me
10.
um that's enough for that all right
hey searching my email
corridor
sorry we missed you we tried we
but we weren't able to deliver your
package today you can reschedule your no
i don't need to reschedule my delivery
we didn't they didn't try no one tried
well you know what maybe they shouldn't
have guaranteed the two
days
how does this work now they didn't that
you didn't get the package so if it's
guaranteed you should be able to get
your money well the order was 25 i'll
refund that and i'll take 10 of those
dollars
i don't think that's how it works